okay
here we go
[Music]
oh
this house
all right
so
uh
thank you very much it was just uh
announced by attorney general barr
that they've caught the killer
of legend de ferro
horribly shot young man wonderful young
man
and uh we have uh just uh this just came
out
two minutes ago so attorney general bar
just announced as you know we named
operation legend after legend to faro
where we're going to be helping out and
are in the process
of helping out cities throughout our
country that have
difficulty with crime in particular
certain types of crimes so that's
really good news they caught the killer
of legend
today we saw joe biden continue to
politicize a
pandemic and to show his appalling lack
of respect for the american people
that's what it is
at every turn biden has been
wrong about the virus ignoring the
scientific evidence and putting
left-wing politics before facts and
evidence sleepy joe opposed both the
china and the europe travel bans you
know that he
opposed the china travel ban that i
instituted very early
and the europe travel ban that i
instituted quite early
if he had followed if we went after
uh i listened to his advice
hundreds of thousands more people would
have died
this is according to many people i
believe that
dr fauci agreed with that he said that
president trump made a great decision
when he put the ban on china
joe biden wants to fling open american
borders allowing the pandemic to
infiltrate every u.s community based on
his policies
he wants to have ridiculous
open borders i've been saying from the
first day i
started campaigning for this great
office that
you have open borders you don't have a
country you don't have a country with
open borders
so he wants open borders the democrats
want open borders
and if you take a look at our southern
border we would have criminals pouring
through
the wall is getting close to 290 miles
long and it's having a huge impact
so we disagree with him on that that's
one of the many different
many things that we disagree with
but while joe biden would allow rioters
and looters and criminals and
millions of illegal aliens to roam free
in our country
he wants the federal government to issue
a sweeping new mandate
to law abiding citizens he wants the
president of the united states with the
mere stroke of a pen to order over 300
million american citizens to wear a mask
for a minimum of three straight months
i guess this just happened he thinks
it's good politics i guess
no matter where they live and no matter
their surroundings
because different states are much
different both in terms of the
atmosphere itself and also in terms of
the corona problem
he does not identify what authority the
president has to issue such a mandate or
how federal law enforcement could
possibly
enforce it or why we would be stepping
on governors throughout our country many
of whom have done a very good job and
they know what
is needed also many of our
50 states are doing the
uh the job at a level that frankly
people are really surprised including
foreign governments that are calling us
constantly and asking
for advice so i want to just say our
governors have
uh worked very hard they've worked with
vice president pence and myself and
everybody else that's been
uh going we have uh scott now involved
and so scott congratulations but you'll
be working with a lot of governors
you've already started
and dr fauci dr burks if the president
has the
unilateral power to order every single
citizen to cover their face in
nearly all instances what other powers
does he have that's why he
refused biden to take questions he
couldn't answer any of them couldn't
answer the questions he refuses to take
questions he never takes questions i
take questions he never takes questions
and you sort of wonder what's going on
because they're not that difficult
some can be nasty but they're not that
difficult
but he never takes questions so he just
i guess left i didn't see it but i guess
he just left the podium
put it in your minds my administration
is a different approach we have urged
americans to wear masks
and i emphasized this is
a patriotic thing to do maybe they're
great
and maybe they're just good maybe
they're not so good
but frankly what do you have to lose
you have nothing to lose so we do and
we've
been saying wear them when it's
appropriate
especially in terms of social distancing
if you can't distance enough
and what do you have to lose
but again it's up to the governors and
we want to have
a certain freedom we want to have a
certain freedom that's what we're about
at the same time we also understand that
each state is different and
is facing unique circumstances you have
very very different
states facing very unique
differences and circumstances we've
entrusted the governors
of each state elected by the people to
develop and enforce their own mass
policies and other policies following
guidance from
the federal government and cdc
we're working with each state to
implement a plan based on the facts and
science
we will continue to urge americans to
wear masks when they
cannot socially distance but we do not
need to
bring the full weight of the federal
government down
on law-abiding americans to accomplish
this goal americans must
have their freedoms and i trust the
american people
and their governors very much i trust
the american people and the governors
want to do the right thing
to make the smart decisions and uh
joe doesn't joe doesn't joe doesn't know
too much
unlike the biden approach our approach
is guided by science that's why we're
focused on protecting the high-risk
americans that
is why we're delivering effective
medical treatments to dramatically
reduce the
fatality rate and that is why we're
developing a vaccine and
therapeutics in record time you'll see
that i think very soon
sleepy joe rejects the scientific
approach in favor of
locking all americans in their basements
for months on end
which i think is something that scott
would be very opposed to
i think i can speak for you we've been
dealing pretty strongly over the last
number of weeks but he wants them
in the basement for months on end and
you have governors that have been very
very
strict on keeping people in their houses
keeping people
in there wherever they may be apartments
and frankly i don't think the results
are necessarily better than other
results
but he wants to shut down our economy
close our schools
and grind society to a halt
and the once it done by a federal decree
this would lead to a cripply long long
lasting depression this would be a
crippling
long-lasting depression and yesterday i
showed you the numbers about how well
we're doing coming back with auto sales
and
auto manufacturing and used car sales
and housing
sales at numbers that nobody would have
believed and we're back and very strong
it's a very strong v it's almost a
straight-up v we'll be discussing that
over the next couple of days but the
economy is coming back and
the employment numbers over the last
three months are a record
in history of our country and we'll be
back next year i think we'll be
maybe even stronger than the previous
year where we set every record in the
book on employment and
stock market by the way our stock market
numbers are
very close to record and nasdaq is
actually record over the last 14 days 14
for 14 times now it's been record
and that's during what we hope will be
the more final stages of the pandemic
so if we did what biden wanted to do it
would shut down our health care system
and lead to a massive increase in
mortality
including suicide overdose heart disease
and countless other physical and mental
harms it is
very very bad on the other side of the
equation
when you do something like that those
shutdowns
are very punitive very
punitive they hurt a lot of people in a
lot of different ways through depression
through suicide through so many other
things
alcohol drugs biden's approach
is regressive it's anti-scientific and
it's very defeatist but it'd be very bad
for our country
while joe biden has been playing
politics from the sidelines he has no
clue
we've been solving problems and
delivering tremendous results
the most advanced and robust testing
system on the planet
the number one producer of ventilators
in the world by far
unprecedented industrial mobilization
biggest since world war ii operation
warp speed to deliver life-saving
treatments and
very soon a vaccine what a
plan by joe biden has actually laid out
would do
we've really already accomplished in
fact many of the things that was well
reported over the last few days
every single thing he said to do every
single thing we did
and we did them well so biden has no
idea
on his own he only knows
what he thinks we should do when he
spews it out and then he
i guess you could say he plagiarizes and
he really did in our case because
every single one of the events i think
kayla we could say that was uh
something we had already done so we'll
defeat the virus but
not by hiding in our basements
he's got to come out of his basement
we'll defeat this virus through a common
sense
mitigation effort shielding those at
highest risk and
unleashing america's medical and
scientific genius which is what it is
and we've already been doing it and
we're very close to having
something that's going to be very very
special in the form of therapeutics and
vaccines to joe
i would say stop playing politics with
the virus too serious
partisan politics has no place here it's
a
shameful situation for
anybody to try and score political
points while we're working to save lives
and defeat the pandemic
in times of national challenge america's
and americans and we are by the way we
are working with countries
from all over the world and they're
trying to learn from us
and some of the countries that you spoke
most well about are having a tremendous
surge right now
but it'll work out but americans must
unite together and they must put
politics aside and have to
really unite for a common good
three vaccines are in the final stage of
clinical trials
are doing really well we're producing
the most
promising vaccine candidates in advance
as you know part of the largest
industrialization ever it's
incredible when i meet with heads of
companies that are doing this
that are the best companies anywhere in
the world uh
it's incredible where they are how
they're doing and the speed
with which they're doing it and also the
speed with which the fda is
approving things because by any other
standard you would have been
two or three years away from being at
the point that we're at
by the end of this week we will have
shipped 1846
rapid point-of-care testing devices to
nursing homes which are
a very important source as you know for
people that are not handling
the plague from china very well
this week alone we're sending 992
testing devices and 450
000 tests to more than 950 nursing homes
across the country
and these tests are uh incredible these
are tests that are
all new very modern and we're also
getting
on the the tests that are not uh done
immediately with the five to 15 minute
timing
when they do send them to a lab they're
coming back now in three days so it's a
three-day process which is about as good
as you can do
you have one day of delivering one day
of receiving and one day
in the lab we're also requiring all
nursing homes to test all members of
their staff at least weekly
by unleashing america's scientific
genius we have delivered effective
treatments the case
fatality rate for americans over 70 has
declined by about 85 percent that's a
fantastic number it's declined that's
case fatality it's declined by 85
percent
europe has seen 40 percent more excess
mortality than the united states
compared to
a non-pandemic year so
you hear the numbers and those numbers
are
very interesting but that's the way it
is we continue to urge all americans to
wash your hands socially distance wear a
mask when necessary and when you cannot
distance and protect very importantly
the vulnerable
protect people that are older
and especially people that have problems
with heart or diabetes or some other
problem earlier today very exciting
news very big news all over the world
they're talking about it
all over the world it was amazing we
finalized a historic peace agreement
between israel
and the united arab emirates
after half a century israel and the
united arab
emirates will fully normalize their
diplomatic
relations nobody thought this was
something that could happen for a long
time
this is the most important diplomatic
breakthrough since the egypt
israel peace agreement was signed
over 40 years ago we have ambassador to
israel david friedman here thank you
david for being here we were
much uh you would agree that this was a
big day for israel and a big day for the
world
good thank you david you've been
fantastic too fantastic ambassador
and representative of our country thank
you very much the deal that was reached
today will enable muslims to have
far greater ability to visit many
historic sites in israel
and to peacefully pray at the al-aqsa
mosque
which is very important to them which
they've wanted to have
access to for many many decades
this is a monumental step to forging
ties
of cooperation in the middle east and i
think you're going to have other
countries come forward i can tell you
we already do and they want to make a
deal
you could have peace in the middle east
and be fantastic
israel is also suspending settlements in
the west bank which is a big deal
a bold step toward achieving peace
israel and the united arab emirates have
also agreed to immediately expand and
accelerate
scientific collaboration to develop
effective treatments and vaccines to
defeat the china virus they've both been
hit
virtually every country has been hit 188
countries
and to save lives in their region and in
their world
so they are working very much on the
vaccines also with us and
again some very good news is going to
take place with respect to that
our unprecedented diplomatic engagements
laid the groundwork for this
historic peace agreement which was just
announced a little while ago today
we will not rest as we continue to work
toward a
world of greater harmony and prosperity
for all
i want to thank prime minister benjamin
netanyahu of israel and crown prince
mohammed
bin zayed of the united arab emirates
two
fantastic people for their vision and
their leadership and i look forward to
hosting them at the white house very
soon to formally sign the agreement
we'll probably be doing it over the next
i would say three weeks and they'll be
coming
to washington so that was a tremendous
day that was a tremendous thing that
happened
and it's great sign we have a lot of
other
interesting things going on with other
nations also having to do with peace
agreements
and a lot of big news is coming over the
next few weeks
and i'm sure you'll be very impressed
and more importantly it's a great thing
for our country great thing for the
world
so thank you very much please go ahead
thank you mr president i appreciate it i
want to ask you about
school age kids and food one of the real
problems when you shut down
schools these are kids on reduced and
free lunch programs
they need these meals to make it through
their day
and with districts shutting down school
what if anything
can the federal government do to make
sure that the kids
still get decent meals as long as the
schools are out
well you know we don't want the schools
shut down we want the schools to open
and especially very young children and
children all children but especially
very young children handle it very well
so we want schools open we don't want to
be in that position we want schools open
we've made payment and we would frankly
if the school isn't going to open we
would much rather follow the child with
the payment
give the money to the child meaning the
parents of the child
and let that let the parents do what
they have to do including bringing the
child to another school
because we're finding that whether it's
parents or
children people want to get back to
school they want to have their
life back some people say they don't
want the democrats don't want schools
open because that's where you have a lot
of polling booths
and if you have a school closed you
can't very easily have polling booths at
the school
and that's becoming i think maybe we'll
be able to show that as fact but
that's another thing that they're doing
to try and keep people away from the
polls
so we have to look into that but it's uh
you've been reading about it i've been
reading about it and i don't like it but
we'd like to see the schools open then
we don't have that problem
good question
what's your understanding of how long
israel will suspend this west bank
annexation plan
uh what do you think tell me well
um we have uh we're putting all our eggs
into the basket
of peace we have an agreement with the
emirates we're going to
nail down all the details embassies over
flights commercial then we're going to
extrapolate that
to the rest of the region how long that
takes i i can't tell you
but that's we've prioritized uh peace
over the sovereignty movement uh but
it's not off the table
it's just something that will be
deferred until the uh we give
peace every single chance and
what do you want the palestinians to
take away from this deal since they're
not really a party to it
well but they are supported largely by
some of the countries that
we're talking to and that have already
signed you know in the case of the one
country but others will be following
and uh i think the palestinians will
without saying it necessarily yet i
think they very much want to be a part
of what we're doing
and i see ultimately the palestinians i
see peace between israel and the
palestinians i see that happening
i think as these very big powerful
wealthy countries come in i think the
palestinians will follow
quite naturally yeah please uh do you
believe that the deal has been reached
without
israel's agreement to temporarily uh
temporarily
suspend annexation say it again could
you make it louder
do you believe the deal could have been
reached without israel's agreement to
temporarily suspend annexation
what do you think about that david it's
interesting
i think you can't do both at the same
time so i think again
prioritize peace sovereignty uh
after peace is given every opportunity
to turn to sovereignty
i don't think the two could have been
done at the same time
have you asked israel to permanently
consider
uh abandoning annexation this is a
temporary process
this morning you said that you do not
want to fund the us postal service
because democrats are trying to expand
voting by mail so i've got two questions
for you one are you threatening to veto
any legislation that includes
funding for the post post office no not
at all no
so you would sign something that does
include funding a separate thing i would
do it
but one of the reasons the post office
needs that much money is to have all of
these millions of ballots coming in from
nowhere and nobody knows from where and
where they're going you saw what
happened in
caitlyn and virginia it was you know 500
000
applications coming in going all over
the state nobody even knows where they
came from you saw what happened in new
york which was
a disaster with congresswoman uh
carolyn maloney it was a it was a basic
disaster and you see
paterson new jersey what's going on
there and we can give you many other
locations and sites
what has happened is that's part of a
big negotiation that's a actually small
part of a big negotiation to get
more money to people that it wasn't
their fault it was china's fault
and post office is part of it another
part of it is they won three and a half
billion dollars
just for the ballots himself why it's so
much i don't know but that's what the
democrats want
but if the bill isn't going to get done
that would mean the post office isn't
going to get funded
and that would also mean that the three
and a half billion dollars isn't going
to be taken care of
so i don't know how you could possibly
use these ballots these mail-in ballots
absentee ballots by the way are fine
but the universal mailings that are just
sent all over the place where people can
grab them and grab stacks of them and
sign them and do whatever you want
that's the thing we're against precisely
the problem is that you're saying you do
not want to give this post office
funding in this coronavirus legislation
they say they need it so they can be
prepared so the pandemic is still going
on in november when the election happens
and people don't feel safe to go vote in
person they can vote by mail
and it can be safe and it can be secure
i can understand the post office and if
we could agree to a bill the overall
bill which is
obviously a much bigger number than just
the post office that would be fine but
they have the post office as one of
their requests it's their request
you said you were against it didn't you
i'm only against what i'm against
is i'm against doing anything where the
people aren't taken care of and the
people aren't being taken care of
properly
we have we want people to get money it
wasn't their fault but they got shut
down they got shut down by china
so whether it's the post office or
whether it's a three and a half
billion dollars you know they're asking
for three and a half billion dollars
just for the universal male imbalance
but they're not willing to make a deal
these are two points within a very big
deal
the thing they want more than anything
else caitlyn and you know this is
bailout money for the states and for the
cities that are in trouble
which for the most part a democrat run
states and cities so
new york has a problem california has a
problem illinois has a tremendous
problem
and others they want to be able to bail
out these states and we don't want to be
doing that or certainly don't want to do
it to the extent they're looking for one
trillion dollars
we don't want to be doing that please go
ahead
they need that money in order to make
the post office work so it can take all
these millions and millions of ballots
and you said that would be fraudulent so
it sounded like you said you know i said
it will end up being fraudulent because
if you look at what's happened over the
last few weeks just look at the few
instances where this has happened it's
turned out to be fraudulent
well if you look at new york it was
fraudulent if you look at paterson new
jersey it was fraudulent
yes there is that the whole thing is a
mess in fact carolyn maloney's
opponent is he's gone crazed he said
they took the election away from him
and he may be right i think they should
redo that election
and if you look at virginia it's
terrible look at some of the things that
have happened in california look at
california where they found
a million non-eligible voters that was
done by judicial watch
tom fitton and judicial watch we have to
have an honest election
and if it's not going to be an honest
election i guess people have to sit down
and
think really long and hard about it but
if the post office if they're not going
to approve a bill
and the post office therefore won't have
the money and if they're not going to
approve
a big bill a bigger bill and they're not
going to have the three and a half
billion dollars for the universal
mail-in votes how can you have those
votes
what would mean is the people will have
to go to the polls and vote
like the old days like two years ago
three years ago four years ago
they have to go to the it doesn't say
anybody's taking the vote away
but it means that the universal mail-ins
don't work absentees do work it's a very
different thing an absentee where you
make an application and you send it in
they send you a vote it's different
but so caitlyn i'm not saying anything
wrong
with voting i want them to vote but that
would mean that they'd have to go to a
voting booth like they used to and vote
voting in person people want to vote by
mail because well they're going to have
to feel safe and they will be safe
and we will make sure that they're safe
and we're not going to have to spend
three and a half billion dollars to do
it
and when you go to a voting it would be
wonderful if we had voting id
and some states have that and some
states don't because they can't get it
passed
most states want it but we want people
to vote
but we want people to vote so when they
vote it means one vote it doesn't mean
ballots all over the place you saw what
would what was happening in virginia
where
piles of ballot applications are dropped
all over the state
they had them named after dogs they had
them named after dead people
we want to have an accurate vote i'm not
doing this for any reason maybe the
other turns out to be my advantage i
don't know i can't tell you that
but i do know this i just want an
accurate vote
and it's a fair question by the way so
does everybody else
okay mr president how does the
accord today between israel and the uae
help struggling and persecuted
christians in the middle east
what how does it help struggling and
persecuted christians in the middle east
the deal today well i think it's going
to i think it's a big start
and you're right about that christians
have been persecuted by some
countries in particular in the middle
east and i think this is a big start
it's going to be a very strong start
very powerful start
and it's something that i will tell you
i've told david i've told every one of
our negotiators
if you look at the way christians have
been treated in some countries it's
it's beyond disgraceful it's
uh if i if i
had information and if i had
absolute proof some of the stories that
we've heard which are not easy which is
not easy to get
i would go in and do a number to those
countries like you wouldn't believe
what they do to christians in the middle
east and it's it's disgraceful
it's disgraceful you're right it's a
very big part of the overall negotiation
and as countries come in for instance
uae has agreed very strongly to
represent us i think they will very well
with respect to
christianity because in the middle east
it's not treated
well it's not treated well at all it's
treated horribly and very unfairly and
uh it's criminal what's happened
and that's for many many years i think
it's a great question and very
it's a very unfair situation please go
ahead thank you mr president
larry kudlow said that there is a
routine check-in call with
china on the phase one trade deal my
question is
what if they bring up tick-tock and and
also wechat
would you engage would you instruct your
team to engage them on that example
we have a deadline of september 15th and
whether it's microsoft i understand and
others are
negotiating we also said that obviously
it's worthless if we don't allow them
into the country so we said that the
united states treasury is going to be
getting something out of this deal
something very substantial
but what we want is total security but
we have a deadline of september 15th
so i know microsoft and others are very
interested in it
but that's our deadline and it has to be
proven to be totally secure
we don't want to have any information
going into china
with what we've been through and i have
to tell you talk about the deal you
mentioned
the phase one deal well the phase one
deal
uh it's very interesting situation
because you've been hearing
the largest order of corn in history the
largest order of soybeans the largest
order of beef
they've done more than they've ever done
so you're gonna have to figure that one
out with
where i'm coming from i could have
because they see my attitude
my attitude toward china is not friendly
but they have gone into orders that are
extremely large
extremely large and our farmers are very
happy
but with what they did with respect to
the pandemic
the the uh the plague that came in from
china
uh it just is a different feeling
it's an incredible deal but i have a
very different feeling
but they are giving they are giving the
midwest our farmers
among the largest orders they've ever
seen somebody told me today bob
lighthouse that it's about 40 percent of
the
of what they're selling now is going to
china
so maybe they're trying to make me
it changed my mind a little bit because
you know my attitude
on china and it's not it hasn't been
very good
well we're not talking to them no we're
talking to the companies
theory is a company but it's a company
within china that means china
and the deal will have to be
substantially beneficial to the united
states and we need total security
okay
can you say whether you yourself think
that
annexation should be off the table for
israel and if so have you communicated
that
so no no no it's something they've
discussed but
israel has agreed not to do that i mean
more than just
off the table they've agreed not to do
it and i think that was
very important and i think it was a
great concession
by israel and i think it was a very
smart concession by israel
but uh david you have anything further
prime minister was
was pretty clear today at his own press
conference that he considers this to be
a temporary suspension
and that the deal would still be open to
him at some point in the future
i'm asking what you think he should do
right now
it's off the table so i can't talk about
sometime into the future that's a big
statement but right now it's off the
table is that a correct statement mr
ambassador
yes the word suspend was chosen
carefully by all the parties suspended
by definition
uh look it up that means temporary
health uh it's off the table back but
it's not
both available go ahead just to follow
the questions that caitlin was asking he
said you do
want an accurate vote you need to arrest
the postmaster general
to reverse some of the policy changes
that have occurred there in order to
prevent delays
no i wouldn't do that at all no i want
the post office to run properly
but which makes sense they would need a
lot more money if they're going to be
taking in
tens of millions of ballots that just
come out of the sky from nowhere
and so they need additional financial
help it's a part of the bill
that the democrats don't want to make
because they want a trillion much bigger
part of the bill they want a trillion
dollars to go to
states that are run by governors who
happen to be democrats who have not done
a good job for many many years
and those estates that owe a lot of
money and need a lot of money and
they're talking about one trillion
dollars so the post
office and the three and a half billion
dollars for the votes themselves which
sounds like a lot of money they're
looking for three and a half billion
dollars think of that three and a half
billion dollars to have
mail-in ballots uh again absentee good
universal mailing very bad uh
please one quick follow-up given that
the negotiations are still ongoing about
whether to get more money
to the postal service why not put more
resources and more money yourself find a
way to do that to make sure there isn't
well they can do it very easily all they
have to do is make a deal
if they make a deal the postal service
is taken care of
the money they need for the mail-in
ballots would be taken care of
if we agree to it that doesn't mean
we're going to agree to it but
all they have to do is make a deal but
again more important to them is not that
that's
a lot of money but in small time
compared to the other what they want to
do
and very very very strongly what they
want to do is bail out cities that are
run by
democrats and have been for many years
and these cities and states have done
very badly and they desperately need
money for that
and we're open to something but we're
not open to the kind of money that they
need go ahead
please three and a half years just one
second please
what are you doing as president to make
sure there is a free and fair election
that's it what are you doing as
president to make sure there is a free
and fair way
everyone talks about russia russia
russia they talk about china china
they talk about all of these different
countries that come in and run
our elections which is false but what
they do
what they don't talk about are things
like very loose
mail-in ballots universal in nature
that frankly russia china
north korea iran all of these countries
that we
are reading about hearing about and in
some cases they're writing about
intelligence-wise
these countries can grab those ballots
or print
forgeries of those ballots and they
would go out and they would have a field
day
this is the easiest way for the mail-in
ballots is the easiest way for
a country like a china or russia or a
north korea
or iran i hear ran too you know that was
part of the report
this would be very easy for them this is
much easier than
well we have been very strong now if you
remember president obama was informed
about russia by the fbi in september
the election was in november president
obama decided
to do absolutely nothing about it people
don't mention that very much anymore
that's a lost fact
but he was informed very powerfully that
they're going to do and president
obama did nothing we have done a lot and
we've really shored it up
but what people can never prepare for
are millions
and millions of mail-in ballots because
they can be forged
they can be captured they can be taken
no well that's a very hard thing to do
we have to make sure that we can do that
please mr president after three and a
half years
you regretted all all the lying you've
done to the american people
all the lying all the dishonesties that
who has done
you have done uh tensorflow
please please
go ahead i wanted to ask about payroll
tax
cut one uh is it gonna be optional or
mandatory for
employers to defer
and not collect the payroll taxes
the payroll tax is very important and a
very big
benefit to people as you know to
companies
because we want the companies to be
strong but now directly to people
and it's a very big number and we're
taking care of it and we
this will go directly to the people the
workers within the company it's a
payroll tax
it's called the payroll tax cut we're
cutting the payroll tax
and it's a very large number and that
will go directly to the workers of the
company
employers collect that through fico will
that be sustainable
are they going to be required not to
collect that much the
you mean later on you mean later on at
all so september 1 when i get my
paycheck
well the employers the employers will
collect it and give it
most likely the employers will collect
it and give it
okay
the first one on domestic politics can't
can't understand the world
she's circulating in social media that
kanwa harris is not eligible to be
to run for vice president because she
was an anchor baby i think
do you or can you definitively say
whether or not pamela harris
is eligible legally meets the legal
requirements to run as vice president
so i just heard that i heard it today
that she doesn't meet the requirements
and by the way the lawyer that wrote
that
piece is a very highly qualified very
talented
lawyer i have no idea if that's right i
would have thought
i would have assumed the democrats would
have checked that out before she gets
chosen to run for vice president
but that's a very serious you you're
saying that they're saying that she
doesn't qualify because she wasn't born
in this country
no she was born in this country but her
parents did not uh
the claims say that her parents did not
receive their permanent residence
yeah i don't know about it i just heard
about it i'll take a look
uh back in the day president follow up
on unga
telecraft recently said that you or
she's hoping that you might be able to
deliver the speech in front of the un
general assembly in person
even though other leaders will be
sending in their video recordings
can you confirm that yeah i'm thinking
about going directly to the u.n to do
the speech
a lot of people will not because of
covid will not be able to be there
uh as you know but i'm thinking i think
it's uh
appropriate if we can do it i'll do it
directly and
again this will not be like in the past
because
some countries won't be able to escape
the problems they're having you know
countries are having a tremendous
problem with
the china virus so we'll see what
happens but
i would prefer doing it i can do it the
other way i can do it
uh viral as they say i can do it in that
form but i'd rather be at the united
nations deliver it
i think it's i think it better
represents the country also i feel sort
of
a at least a semi obligation as the
president of the united states to be
at the united nations to deliver what
will be an important speech
well the room won't be empty uh the room
will have different people there and
representatives
of countries but i can understand how
it's you know it's very difficult for
countries to be there they won't be
there only for that reason
they'd love to be there i've already had
people call in fact say
a couple of them i'd love to be there if
you want i'll be there i said don't be
there
you don't have to be there uh no the
room would be uh
i think the room will not be although
there may be a spacing requirement like
you have in this room
this room was always packed this room
would be packed again
if we had the seats open but you have a
spacing requirement so i understand that
the united nations they may have
that too yes please thank you mr
president i have a question on the peace
deal but if
you don't mind could i defer my
questions to you from
epic times sure yes please
please thank you i would like to ask
your
opinion about what recently happened in
hong kong recent attack on
uh press freedom in hong kong and jimmy
uh
lai was arrested his newsroom was raided
how will the u.s respond to this well i
think it's a terrible thing but one
thing that we have done you know we gave
tremendous incentives to
hong kong because of freedom we want
freedom
and we were giving tremendous economic
incentives to hong kong
and we have now withdrawn all of those
incentives and it will be impossible for
hong kong to compete
with the united states with respect to
that
it just won't be because we've taken all
of the incentives away
if you look at china with the world
trade organization as an example
they're getting tremendous because
they're considered a developing nation
which is ridiculous why should they be a
developing nation but we're not
and they get tremendous incentives we
have by the way uh
told them it's unacceptable and we've
been we've been
doing that for a long time they
understand exactly how we feel
and big changes are being made but with
respect to hong kong they get tremendous
financial incentives
so that they could do business to
compete in the world
we've now withdrawn all of those
incentives it's going to be very hard
for hong kong to compete
and i will tell you that the united
states and
i say this from any standpoint you want
to hear it we'll end up making a lot
more money because of it because we lost
a lot of business to hong kong
we made it very convenient for people to
go there for companies to go there
we've withdrawn all of that and the
united states will be a big beneficiary
from an economic standpoint
but i hate to see what happened to hong
kong because freedom is a great thing
thank you all very much thank you thank
you very much
i